[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend die offensive in der ost
ukraine hat begonnen das was russland
spezialoperation nennt ist nach den
worten von außenminister lavrov in eine
neue phase getreten
hier spricht von der schlacht um den don
bass und fordert seine westlichen
partner weiter auf mit waffen zu helfen
die freiheit so hatte präsident seelands
die kürzlich gesagt muss besser
bewaffnet sein als die tyrannei dass
deutschland mit dafür sorgen werde dass
sich die ukraine zur wehr setzen kann
versprach am abend der bundeskanzler was
das für waffenlieferungen heißt dazu
gleich mehr zunächst in die ukraine dara
hassanzadeh mit einem überblick über das
kriegsgeschehen
ukrainische soldaten im donbass seit
tagen haben sie sich in stellung
gebracht gegen die russiche
großoffensive die heute begonnen hat es
sind bilder der ukrainischen armee sie
suggerieren eine gelassenheit von der
wir nicht wissen ob sie bei den soldaten
wirklich so vorherrscht
wir können jetzt sagen dass die
russischen kräfte nach langer
vorbereitung den kampf um das don bass
gestartet haben diese offensive wird
einen sehr großen teil ihrer armee
binden
die front im osten der ukraine ist 480
kilometer lang die kleinstadt criminale
hat die russische armee bereits
eingenommen und russland hat eine
deutliche übermacht an panzern und
artillerie über 60 stellung der ukraine
wurden heute beschossen
heftiger angriffe auf mario pohl seit 55
tagen halten ukrainische soldaten ihre
stellungen
verschanzt in einem stahlwerk mit einem
tarif von elf quadratkilometern das
heutige ultimatum russlands sich zu
ergeben haben die ukrainischen soldaten
abgelehnt im inneren des stahlwerks
harren noch immer tausende zivilisten
aus
einen humanitären korridor hat die
russische armee erneut verhindert
die westlichen staaten versuchen alles
um unsere militär operation möglichst in
die länge zu ziehen das zeigen die
gelieferten waffen damit provozieren die
usa und ihre verbündeten das regime in
kiew bis zum letzten ukraine weiter
kämpfen zu lassen
moskau aktionismus dem die menschen in
florians ihre lebensweise entgegensetzen
die stadt liegt nahe der front in der
ost ukraine trotz luftalarm bleiben die
menschen ruhig sehr ruhig
wir glauben an unsere armee und an
unseren sieg und daran dass die kämpfe
nichts libyen zu erreichen werden wir
sind zuversichtlich wir wollen hier in
unserer stadt friedlich leben ohne
bomben und luftangriffe wir werden sehen
ob das möglich ist wir werden bis zum
allerletzten moment bleiben mein kaffee
und meine freunde
sie können nicht bis zum letzten moment
warten die patienten aus einem
sterbehospiz in der provinz donets werk
evakuiert
die menschen die transportfähig sind die
anderen müssen bleiben den tod und die
russische großoffensive vor augen
wie weit die russische armee im donbass
vorträgen wird es hängt von ihnen ab den
ukrainischen soldaten doch ohne
ausreichend schwere waffen wird es ein
äußerst ungleicher kampf
wir wollen dass ein ordner mit general
ag über ein rams wir uns auch heute
abend wieder zur verfügung steht jungen
an
torchancen
wie schätzen sie diese offensive der
russischen armee ein das fand ich
interessant die ukrainische seite heute
mal als vorsichtig bezeichnet hat
also ich schätze die offensive so ein
dass auf einer großen breite 84 km ihr
korrespondent
angegriffen wird und eine solche
angriffe auf dieser breite verlangt
viele kräfte dem setzten die ukraine
ihren kampfeswillen ihre kampfmoral
entgegen und natürlich sind die ukraine
nicht völlig nicht ausgerüstet sag ich
einmal sondern sie haben ihre waffen sie
aber auch zum teil moderne waffen wenn
ich beispielsweise an kampfdrohnen denke
und dass die dinge mehr um auch damit
ist man in der lage panzer zu zerstören
aber natürlich wäre es im gefecht gegen
panzer schützenpanzer und artillerie gut
für die ukraine wenn sie entsprechende
waffen hätten um mit gleichen mitteln
zurückschießen und zurückschlagen zu
können denn russland konzentriert ja
jetzt alle kräfte auf den osten auf den
don bosco er schon seit jahren gekämpft
wird was ist ihre erwartung wie
erfolgreich wird die russische armee
dort nun am ende sein wie kann sie sein
denn es ist ja dann auch eine große
feldschlacht
also ich glaube dass das ähnlich sein
wird und ähnlich verlaufen wird wie bei
dem angriff auf kiew zu anfang des
krieges die russen werden in den ersten
tagen einige erfolge erzielen aber sie
werden sich möglicherweise auch im don
was dann nicht durchsetzen können wobei
das minimalziel von wladimir putin
wahrscheinlich ist in donners vor dem 9
mai also dem tag der großen parade über
für den sieg über hitler-deutschland
entsprechend zunehmen um dieses in die
siegerstaaten entsprechend mit
einzureihen
feldschlacht das ist ein punkt den ich
in dieser form noch nicht sehe weil auch
dieses gelände in diesem bereich relativ
schwierig ist für panzer angriffe die
dann breit angelegt sein müssten von
daher wird das auch wieder in vielen
bereichen ein kampf ich sag das mal von
infanterie ausgerüstete infanterie auf
der ukrainischen seite unter dem gegen
gepanzerte fahrzeuge auf der anderen
seite man ist mario pohl noch immer
umkämpft jedenfalls eben von den
ukrainischen verteidiger noch nicht
aufgegeben und solange das so ist bindet
der kampf um opel ja auch russische
kräfte abgesehen mal von dem symbol wert
wie wichtig ist für die russische seite
die einnahme von mario pohl
oder die russin möchte man in jedem fall
so schnell wie möglich einnehmen daher
auch ich sag das mal vorsichtig die
aufforderung zwei aufforderungen im
prinzip die waffen zu strecken für die
ukrainische soldaten das werden die
ukraine nicht tun das lässt ich glaube
ich ziemlich sicher sagen und von daher
wird dass der kampf um mario pohl wird
noch einige tage weitergehen ob er dann
am ende erfolgreich wird für die russen
lässt sich zurzeit nicht sagen es bindet
kräfte wie sie richtig festgestellt
haben und das ist auf jeden fall auch
von größerem wert dann für den
schlachten die in den anderen teilen des
don wasser folgen würden
haben sie denn ranz kenntnisse eine
einschätzung wie die ausrüstung der
ukraine ist können können sie diesen
bedarf einschätzt es sind ja offenbar
auch waffen aus amerikanischen bestand
jetzt eingetroffen
also zunächst einmal müssen wir
festhalten dass die ukrainische armee
sich in den acht jahren sollte an
lektionen der krim rüstungs mäßig schon
deutlich verbessert hat wir gucken mal
auf die großen geschütze und auf die
schweren waffen wir müssen genauso
gucken auf alles was im elektronischen
bereich stattfindet wir müssen genauso
gucken auf das was mit kommunikation
führung führungsfähigkeit zu tun hat und
da haben die ukrainische streitkräfte in
den letzten sieben wochen unter beweis
gestellt dass sie dieses mit die
offensichtlich gut beherrschen
vielleicht sogar besser verschloss die
russen dazu kommt ein weiterer teil der
wichtig ist nämlich die tatsache dass
wir wieder auf die russische logistik
werden sehen müssen ob diese dieses mal
funktioniert oder zumindest besser
funktioniert als es in den folien oder
bei den kämpfen und kiew der fall war
deshalb bundeskanzler schals der ukraine
heute volle unterstützung zugesagt aber
eben auch darauf hingewiesen dass es am
meisten sinn mache schweres gerät aus
ehemals sowjetischen beständen zu
schicken ist das für sie nachvollziehbar
also grundsätzlich ist die aussage des
bundeskanzlers richtig wenn man den
ukrainischen soldaten gerät gibt welches
sie kennen können sie praktisch auf die
panzer schützenpanzer und die geschütze
auf sitzen und den kampf aufnehmen ich
glaube aber auch dass eine künstliche
barriere gebaut wird von unserer seite
her was die nutzung unserer
waffensysteme also beispielsweise des
leopard 1 oder fertige schützen oder
schützenpanzer marder angeht auch diese
waffen sind zwar vielleicht nicht so
einfach zu bedienen und die ukrainischen
soldaten müssen dafür ausgebildet werden
aber auch diese ausbildung kann man ich
formuliere das mal so wenn es
erforderlich sind schnelldurchgang
durchziehen von daher wäre dieses gerät
für die ukraine ausgesprochen wertvoll
gewesen vor allen dingen dann wenn man
diese entscheidung vielleicht vor fünf
wochen geführt hatte die einschätzung
von general de gaulle rams herzlichen
dank für heute abend und wir schauen
dann auf die diskussion in berlin der
druck auf bundeskanzler scholz sich beim
thema waffenlieferungen zu bewegen
jedenfalls klarer zu positionieren war
über das osterwochenende gewachsen dass
das wochenende hatte noch mit einer
weiteren milliarden zusage der
bundesregierung an die ukraine begonnen
die kritik aus der cdu und auch von
grünen und fdp blieb aber geld kann die
nötigen waffen nicht ersetzen diesem
argument widersprach der bundeskanzler
heute sehr entschlossen die ukraine
bekommt waffen direkt von der deutschen
rüstungsindustrie und die rechnung wird
bezahlt daniel ponce berichtet es wirkt
wie ein europa der zwei
geschwindigkeiten in der ukraine steigt
jeden tag jede nacht die zahl der toten
jede stunde zählt aus ukrainischer sicht
das ist die eine geschwindigkeit die
andere klingt mit blick auf
waffenlieferungen heute morgen noch so
die bundesregierung ist dabei diese
möglichkeiten auszuloten oder schuld
wird auch heute wieder diese gespräche
führen die notwendig sind um dann die
nächsten schritte zu beraten beraten
gespräche führen ausloten
verantwortungsvolles regierungshandeln
nennen das die einen unterlassene
hilfeleistung historische schuld gar die
anderen die union kündigte gestern an
den bundestag selbst einen antrag
einzubringen zum thema lieferung
schwerer waffen sollte scholz sich nicht
zuvor selbst entscheiden bewegen es gibt
schwere zweifel an deutschland an
deutschlands zuverlässigkeit nicht nur
in der ukraine auch in polen in den
baltischen ländern viele stellen die
frage kann man sich auf deutschland noch
verlassen nicht nur bei der frage der
waffenlieferung sondern auch bei einem
möglichen nato bündnisfall und diese
zweifel aufkommen zu lassen ist die
schwere bürde die jetzt schon auf dieser
regierung und auf olaf scholz lastet
schon zuvor wuchs die kritik auch
innerhalb der koalition zuletzt immer
lauter
zwei ausschussvorsitzende legten nach
ihrer jüngsten kritik hatte nach
finanzielle militärhilfe könne die
schnelle lieferungen auch schwerer
waffen nicht ersetzen so anton hofreiter
im zeitungsinterview denn
die zeit drängt weil der krieg tobt es
gibt eine offensive sie sehen die bäder
sie senden die weder jeden tag und warum
das im kanzleramt bisher nicht gesehen
würde müssen sie den bundeskanzler
fragen zu erklären ist das nicht eher
führung angeboten und hat gesagt wer in
welt hat führung bestellt jetzt wollen
wir die bestellung aus einlösen und der
sorge es auf führen während andere nato
länder bereits schwere waffen liefern
und auch sagen welche wurde aus
deutschland vor allem bekannt was nicht
gehe erst dies ist es dürfe nicht
bekannt werden was geliefert wird dann
die bundeswehr könne kaum etwas liefern
und was lieferbar sei könnten die
ukraine nicht bedienen heute nachmittag
dann eine videokonferenz mit
us-präsident beiden weiteren
regierungschefs sowie spitzen von nato
und eu danach dies wir haben die
deutsche rüstungsindustrie gebeten und
zu sagen welches material sie im
nächsten zeit liefern kann die ukraine
hat sich nun von dieser liste eine
auswahl zu eigen gemacht und wir stellen
ihr das für den kauf notwendige geld zur
verfügung darunter sind wie bisher
waffen die anzahl abwehrwaffen
beinhalten
luftabwehr geräte darunter gehören auch
andere dinge wie munition von direkten
lieferungen schwerer waffen aus
deutschland sprach scholz erneuten
lediglich davon dass nato-partner die
waffen sowjetischer bauart in die
ukraine liefern ersatz bekommen könnten
aus deutschland es ist ein weiterer
schritt in die richtige richtung nicht
werden olaf scholz sagt dass wir partner
länder unterstützen die wiederum direkt
waffen an die ukraine liefern wie zum
beispiel polen die slowakei oder auch
andere länder dann ist es schon mal was
aber angesichts des heftigen abnutzungs
krieges müssten wir natürlich auch
direkt liefern auch aus der union hieß
es am abend das heute zugesagte reiche
nicht das thema dürfte also weiter
schwelen in berlin während in der
ukraine
der krieg weitergeht
aus berlin ist mir jetzt der ukrainische
botschafter andrej melik zugeschaltet
schon guten abend herr botschafter
guten abendrot osten sie haben in den
letzten wochen ja vehement gefordert
dass deutschland mehr tun müsse gerade
was die lieferung von waffen an gehe hat
sie zufriedengestellt was der
bundeskanzler heute in seinem statement
angekündigt hat jedenfalls erklärt hat
wie seine linie ist
wir glauben dass auch dass die
bundeswehr nach wie vor fähig wäre uns
die waffen zu liefern die wir gerade
benötigen nur ein beispiel marder
schützenpanzer die bundeswehr hatte nach
unseren angaben über 400 an der zahl und
nur ein geringer teil davon ist
eingebunden in missionen in litauen zum
beispiel und wir haben auch angebot von
deutschen rüstungsindustrie dazu dass
diese maschinen auch fast innerhalb von
wenigen wochen ersetzt werden können und
wir hoffen nach wie vor dass das diese
dass diese entscheidung auch dazu
benutzt wird das dass diese waffen so
schnell wie möglich an die ukraine
geschickt werden können sie hoffen dass
noch aber kann sehr stolz hat jetzt kein
kurswechsel angekündigt dh sie können
nicht damit rechnen dass leopard panzer
oder marder in die ukraine geliefert
werden wenn sie sagen sie haben
informationen dass das doch möglich wäre
die bundesregierung sagt aber es gebe
keine frei verfügbaren
gerätschaften trauen sie also den
bekundungen der bundesregierung
also wir wissen dass was was wir an
informationen haben auch von der
rüstungsindustrie
unternehmen ein weiteres beispiel
transport
transportfahrzeuge fuchs also es gibt
acht jahrhundert an der zeit in der
bundeswehr und auch diese werden bald
durch boxer ersetzte von den industrie-
und es steht nicht auf dem wege dass
diese diese geräte diese maschinen für
den truppentransport an die ukraine
geliefert werden können wir wissen nicht
warum das nicht geschieht sie hatten der
bundesregierung schon im februar eine
wunschliste vorgelegt die unter anderem
eben kampfpanzer flugzeuge artillerie
auflistete wie viel von dem was sie
benötigen bekommen sie jetzt von der
deutschen industrie also was steht auf
der industrie liste denn das ist ja ein
großes angebot der deutschen
bundesregierung zu sagen ihr bestellt
und wir zahlen
ja das problem ist dass diese quasi
bereinigte liste die wir bekommen haben
von der bundesregierung vor ein paar
wochen dass auch diese liste gar keine
schwere war von sich befinden und
deswegen wir wissen gar nicht was für
diese eine milliarde euro die erst heute
verkündet wurde was dargestellt werden
kann wenn weil die waffen die wir
brauchen die die sind halt nicht auf
diese liste die ausladung wenn wir
zurückschauen herr botschafter die
ausladung von bundespräsident steinmeier
der in kiew nicht erwünscht war hat im
nachgang ja zu einigen verwerfungen
nicht mal geführt gerade im verhältnis
in ihrem verhältnis zur spd zuletzt am
gut wochenende ein twitter battle
geradezu mit dem früheren spd aus
minister gabriel in dem sie sich
gegenseitig artigkeit vorgeworfen haben
ist ihr treffen morgen mit der spd
chefin esken eine art versöhnungsbesuch
ja wir sind im austausch mit fresken und
ich schätze auch
diese dieses verhältnis das wir haben
ich hoffe dass dieses treffen auch
morgen dazu
genutzt wird um eben auch die spd-spitze
zu überzeugen dass die ukraine eben
gleich sehr bald auch diese schweren
waffen systeme benötigt und das wir
hoffen dass auch bei der bundesregierung
diese entscheidung doch fallen kann also
sie waren darauf und sie bleiben dabei
halten diese forderung aufrecht auch
weil sie besondere erwartungen gerade an
die deutsche regierung
herantragen wegen der deutschen
energiepolitik die regierungen in der
vergangenheit mit russland aufgebaut
haben
wir glauben und das auch also diese
fehle noch korrigiert werden sollten und
wir hoffen dass auch dieses embargo für
russisches gas und öl auch kommen er
muss dann allein in diesem jahr wird
erwartet dass aus deutschland knapp 32
milliarden euro an russland fließen
werden und das heißt dass ein
halbjähriges militärbudget russlands
damit finanziert würde und wir hoffen
dass auch diese entscheidung sehe ist
schwierig das wissen wir wir verstehen
dass auch die deutsche wirtschaft in
mitleidenschaft gezogen werden kann aber
an angesicht diese bilder die wir sehen
auch gerade aus dem osten der ukraine
dass diese entscheidung längst an der
zeit ist sagt der ukrainische
botschafter anderem anic herzlichen dank
nach berlin danke draußen und in unserem
heute journal update ist der grünen
politiker anton hofreiter zu gast der in
den letzten tagen hierzulande der
schärfste kritiker von olaf scholz war
im gespräch dann mit nazan kippte mehr
und nun weitere nachrichten gründe aus
die bundespolizei hat in deutschland
knapp
360.000 kriegsflüchtlinge aus der
ukraine registriert
laut bundesinnenministerium könnte die
zahl höher liegen da es nach wie vor
keine stationären kontrollen gibt polen
hat zugleich mehr als 28 millionen
geflüchtete aufgenommen im
westukrainischen länder polen gemeinsam
mit der ukraine ein containerdorf zur
unterbringung von
350 menschen eingeweiht dabei forderte
polenz ministerpräsident moral jetzt
gehe erneut schnellere finanzhilfen der
eu für die flüchtlingshilfe
russland weist mehr als 30 europäische
diplomaten aus den benelux ländern und
aus österreich aus es handele sich um
eine vergeltungsmaßnahme heißt es aus
dem außenministerium in moskau für die
ausweisung russischer diplomaten aus den
betroffenen ländern
europäische staaten haben seit
kriegsbeginn mehr als 300 russische
botschaftsangehörige zu unerwünschten
personen erklärt
im nahen osten nehmen die spannungen zu
als reaktion auf einen raketenangriff
militanter palästinenser hat israel ein
ziel im gazastreifen beschossen mit der
andauernden terrorwelle in israel will
sich auch der un-sicherheitsrat befassen
die israelische luftwaffe hat bei ihrem
angriff eine waffenfabrik der
radikalislamischen hamas zerstört zuvor
war eine rakete aus dem gazastreifen
richtung israel abgeschossen worden
die pläne von bundesarbeitsminister heil
zur langfristigen absicherung der rente
in deutschland haben ein gemischtes echo
ausgelöst die fdp begrüßt vor allem den
einstieg in eine aktien renten die dafür
geplanten zehn milliarden euro seien
allerdings nur ein kleiner beitrag heißt
es aus der deutschen rentenversicherung
angesichts eines jahreshaushaltes von
340 milliarden euro derzeit fließen
bereits jährlich rund 100 milliarden vom
bund in die rentenkasse zu corona die
sieben tage ins events ist erneut
deutlich gesunken auf heute knapp
670 wegen der osterfeiertage spricht das
robert koch institut allerdings von
einer erhöhten untererfassung wegen
niedrigerer instanzen ist in spanien die
masken pflicht ab morgen weitgehend
aufgehoben und in den usa wurde die
masken pflicht in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln von einer
bundesrichterin gekippt das gilt auch
für flughäfen und bahnhöfe die
us-regierung prüft einen einspruch gegen
das urteil und mehrere lokale behörden
kündigten unabhängig davon eine eigene
masken pflicht an
der lok down den china seiner metropole
shanghai verpasst hat gilt auf
unbestimmte zeit seit bald drei wochen
sind die meisten der 26 millionen
einwohner in ihren wohnungen gefangen
trotzdem gibt es täglich rund 20.000
neuinfektionen und nun auch erste
todesopfer keine corona toten das war
bisher stets die behauptung gewesen und
begründung für die rigide 0-coup it
strategie doch inzwischen wurden zehn
opfer bestätigt und die verzweiflung
über nahrungsknappheit oder fehlende
medizinische behandlung nimmt zu
shanghai zwischen chaos und schönem
schein unfall berichtet
solche bilder gibt es fast nie aus china
das volk protestiert gegen die
machthaber im chinesischen netz
schockieren aufnahmen von polizisten die
shanghaier bürgerfest nehmen die
behörden zwingen sie ihre wohnungen zu
verlassen
denn daraus soll eine quarantäne
unterkunft entstehen chinas führung
fürchtet im corona chaos zu versinken
wenn
sie so weitermachen gibt es für china
keine hoffnung mehr sagt der polizist zu
der festgenommenen frau wir werden bald
krieg mit amerika haben das wissen sie
doch nur die kommunistische partei kann
uns retten
die zustände in den provisorischen
quarantäne unterkünften sind oft
verheerend dreckige toiletten die
menschen sind ein gefecht jeder der
positiv getestet wird muss in eine
quarantäne unterkunft egal ob er
symptome hat oder nicht
bye bye ist in der größten shanghais
50.000 betten es gebe keine ausreichende
medizinische versorgung erklärt sie uns
es gibt keine warmen duschen das licht
ist die ganze nacht an
offizielle der stadt besuchen die
abgeriegelten wohnviertel und feiern
sich und ihr krisen management
die propaganda zeigt quarantäne
unterkünfte die wie hotels wirken die
null kowitz strategie funktioniere so
die botschaft auch die
lebensmittelversorgung laufe auf
hochtouren aber das netz ist voll mit
menschen die hunger haben
was ist wenn ich verhungere ich bin so
hungrig habt doch mitleid mit mir
wir haben keine band mehr wir haben kein
toilettenpapier sagte diese frau
in shanghai leben auch einige tausend
deutsche viele müssen jetzt mit einer
schwierigen lage klar kommen wir
sprechen mit familie ahlrichs seit fast
drei wochen dürfen sie ihre wohnung
nicht mehr verlassen
wie lange die quarantäne noch geht sagt
ihnen keiner
die eigenen vier wände nicht verlassen
man ist angewiesen auf externe
lebensmittel zulieferung also es ist ja
unter gefangenen situation
shanghai im ausnahmezustand und die
propaganda zeigt tanzende bürger in der
quarantäne
chinas wirtschaft leidet inzwischen
unter der null kowitz strategie und auch
die weltwirtschaft wäre von weiteren
lockdown betroffen etwa durch engpässe
bei den weltweiten lieferketten darauf
hat heute der iwf hingewiesen der sich
bei seiner frühjahrstagung vor allem mit
den folgen des kriegs beschäftigt vor
allem wegen des krieges in der ukraine
hat der internationale währungsfonds
seine prognose für die weltwirtschaft
deutlich gesenkt erhebliche risiken
sieht der iwf vor allem für europa
valerie haller hintergrund ist eben auch
dass die pandemie nicht ausgestanden ist
ja da sind ja sozusagen zwei
schockwellen auf die weltwirtschaft
eingebrochen und dennoch hatte iwf
tatsächlich seine wachstumsprognose vor
allem wegen des krieges
heruntergeschraubt weil die nach der
pandemie erwartete erholung nun
vermutlich dahin ist mit heftigen
auswirkungen auf wachstum und inflation
hat der iwf im januar noch mit einem
weltweiten wirtschaftswachstum von 4,4
prozent gerechnet geht er nun von 3,6
prozent aus klingt erstmal noch nicht
nach besonders viel bedeutet aber 660
milliarden euro wirtschaftsleistung
dürften der weltgemeinschaft durch den
krieg entgehen besonders betroffen ist
europa am stärksten aber natürlich die
kriegsgegner selbst die ukraine und
russland
laut iwf steht russland wegen der
sanktionen vor einer tiefen rezession wo
und wie zeigen die strafmaßnahmen denn
bereits wirkung also wo natürlich zeigen
sie sich erstmal in russland selbst die
russische notenbank chefin hat
überraschend eingestanden die wirtschaft
könne nicht ewig von reserven leben
tatsächlich müssen sich russische
exporteure wegen der sanktionen neue
handelspartner suchen aber auch die
logistik wird immer schwieriger ein
riesenproblem für russlands export und
import russische schiffe unterliegen
einem embargo und auf anderen wegen geht
nicht viel weil lkw-fahrer und natürlich
auch die fahrer dazu fehlen das trifft
auf ausländische unternehmen ebenfalls
die in russland produzieren land ist zum
beispiel der mutterkonzern von opel
setzt die produktion in russland nun
vollständig aus der grund fehlende baut
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt und
eine meldung vom fußball das
dfb-pokal-halbfinale hsv gegen sc
freiburg ist soeben zu ende gegangen mit
einem 3 1 auswärtssieg für freiburg
damit steht der aktuelle tabellenfünfte
im finale der gegner wird morgen
ermittelt im zweiten halbfinale zwischen
rb leipzig und union berlin
in südafrika gilt nach dem schweren
unwetter an der ostküste der notstand
staatschef hammer poser sprach von einer
humanitären katastrophe
die schnelle hilfe erfordere mehr als
440 menschen kamen ums leben viele
werden noch vermisst
nahe der küstenstadt durban wurden etwa
40.000 menschen obdachlos da auch die
straßen zum hafen beschädigt sind ist
die versorgung mit lebensmitteln und
treibstoff in ganz südafrika
beeinträchtigt
soweit der tag aus unserer sicht wir
empfehlen ihnen jetzt 37 grad über einen
trend der immer noch zunimmt die
selbstoptimierung gesünder essen bewusst
leben den körper perfektionieren ob es
glücklich macht dazu jetzt die
interessante reportage und um 0.30
meldet sich also nazan guckte mir mit
unserem heute-journal update so ist es
bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend zwischen einem hoch über
skandinavien und dem tief wie rechtlich
von uns kommt zu uns doch eher kühle
luft und heute gab es ja nicht nur
dichtere wolken sondern auch mal etwas
regen und etwas regen beschäftigt uns
auch in der nacht am alpenrand im osten
sind die wolken dichter im westen ist es
dagegen meistens klar und die
temperaturen sinken auf plus drei grad
an der ostsee und -3 grad hier im
oberpfälzer wald milder bleibt es in der
uckermark und ganz im westen mit 6 bis 4
grad das temperaturgefälle beschäftigt
uns ja schon viele tage und auch morgen
wird das erhalten bleiben im osten
bleibt es bei 10 bis 15 grad eher kühl
im westen ist es bei 14 bis 19 grad
deutlich milder und ähnlich wie heute
strahlt auch morgen in der westhälfte
wieder die sonne im osten gibt es
dichtere wolken besonders hier im
nordosten und hier und da reicht es auch
mal für einen regenschauer in den
nächsten tagen ändert sich bei dem
nordostwind wenig und über den norden
ziehen dichtere wolken im süden gibt es
dagegen viel sonnenschein und erst am
samstag kann es dann vielleicht im
südwesten mai für ein gewitter reichen
bei 10 bis 21 grad was aber auffällt ist
dass es im nordosten deutlich kälter ist
als im westen sehen sie hier mal am
beispiel von rostock da liegen die
temperaturen nämlich bis zum ende des
monats doch meist nur wenig über zehn
grad anders in köln da liegen sie
meister 15 bis maximal 20 grad